hey guys I'm Jess and I'm ed and we're
gonna be doing another episode of
GameSpot plays for you this time we're
digging into the hot new city skylines
city new skyline skylines which is
really hot today it has its like double
plural yeah it's the best I'm obsessed
with this game yeah it is fantastic it's
from colossal order which is a small
finish studio like 13 people also yeah
and Paradox Interactive so I'm just
gonna jump right in yeah obviously it
looks a lot like since a 2013 9 duh I
don't think they're really hiding the
influences very much like it's got like
the tilt-shift it's got like just that
nice bright why rent Western city feel
yeah and so although the same ideas but
it does send many more things better
than yeah so interesting cuz I feel like
it's one of those games that you get a
first look at and think it's a clone but
it's actually extending with so many
different elements I mean like SimCity
2013 went in a lot of good direction
yeah I just didn't completely get there
and I think us City sky land basically
picks up where they left off and this is
like the only city built on the market
right now and it is the only one you
need really yeah this is a thriving
insanely huge town my wonderful death is
actually my second time yeah and where I
learnt full-line mistakes and so if you
played like a city builder like SimCity
before you you will probably know what
you're in for so here is my like I call
this city of Riverrun and yeah
so you basically zone districts
residential commercial industrial yeah
and then you pick up the problems that
you create for yourself okay so you
grouped everything pretty much grouped
everything so your blue is your
commercial greens residential and then
you industries up the back there yeah I
mean like with all good cities you will
know that for the industry is away from
the residential except for these guys
who are basically my workers
it's all about keeping your citizens
happy one feature you know SimCity 2013
had all that dumb sim stuff how you go
down to the floor and see the sims say
oh no I need more schools so this game
yes has a Twitter feed yeah it's going
to delight in the fact that citizens use
really really - tags oh ha ok so here is
where you'll find out what your city
needs like from the city so say all the
Williams is really like excited about
the solar power plant yeah see exactly
where he lives and um another thing it
improves on from SimCity is that some
say 2013 was touting their glass box
sort of system where like residents
would actually exist and they get a job
and go to a house and all that kind of
stuff really good idea yeah except in
Sim City every resident didn't actually
have a home they just went to the
nearest house they went to the nearest
jobs all right it was a specifically
program no but somehow they managed to
actually realize it so every resident
has a name yeah every resident has a
specific house and a specific job and if
you mess with that stuff they will you
know then have to adjust yeah so they
get super upset like when you need to
build a road over their house or even
build roads near their house I've
noticed when in my short time playing
they get super upset yeah so everything
like actually affects everything which
is really great and and it feels natural
to so everything is generally like a
very gradual process so if you say put
this sewage you know downstream from the
water containment yeah slowly but surely
everyone will start drinking their own
poop right and it will affect things
that's a worry so what's great about
city skyline is that has like a million
more options for everything so yeah
roads are basically the most important
part of like any city bowling game no
it's
and this is way more options whereas
instant City you can do lots of
different curved roads and you can like
set like prefabricated roundabouts and
download new intersections and stuff
from you still so does that involve a
lot of planning in advance like I mean I
had to delete my first town about 10
minutes into playing because I'd already
messed up yeah I mean what's the
learning curve like weiming you need I
think you need definitely need to fail
your first city right because you need
to learn from this that you yeah what
what's important in this city builder
and yeah I quickly weren't that you know
you can make the nicest city in the in
the world but if you don't have a good
road system like no one can get anywhere
like goods in the industry can't get to
the commercial stores you know residents
can't get home they can't get to work so
yeah is if you have a good road system
like you will be richly rewarded
yeah and I'm colossal order actually
made these cities in motion games which
were primarily based around public
transit in Europe yeah and so they
bought a lot of those kind of like ideas
and sort of traffic management in
traffic AI sort of learning to this
games yeah tropic is very important so
how is the AI it's wrong it's really
good I mean I feel like it's really good
yeah yeah people will get in the right
lane to turn the green lines to turn and
you know rats are your best friend
especially for heavy yeah because the
more intersections you have yeah the
more part there is and obviously there
are heaps and infographics the cities
and well you know I mentioned public
transit yeah the public transportation
system in this game is intense yeah
there's like bus systems but whereas in
some city you could just place a bus
stop and then they just randomly go
around and pick people laughs yeah you
know you can set bus routes so I've got
like a whole bunch of different bus
routes here semi how residents can get
to like work and like to the shops
itself and drag lines and ads
on the floor you just set like a loop in
the town like along the road facing then
that's the bus laughs yeah I like
regular bus truth so you underground
metro system oh my god it's gonna move
those someone's house here they let you
take the train to this industrial area
yeah my stuff I'll build some tunnels oh
okay matching up the things yeah that's
really handy for when you get a busy
town that's true and then you just say
the line so you can go from this station
to this station the smiles a server I do
it for the smiles and there's like a
train system above ground train and then
there's Harbor and yeah all the stuff
that you would think of but way more
comprehensive in SimCity ever was yeah
actually need to get into the
nitty-gritty of everything like so now
you're piping whereas in SimCity 2013
all your electricity and water was just
basically fed through the roads yeah not
so in city's skyline you have to do that
separately so your pipes are like all
these little things like down on that
map and water and sewage goes in the
same pipe or they are the garbage you
know it has the same Simpson II sort of
idea that will show you with the green
on the road where which areas are
covered and so on and so forth hospitals
and fire departments and police
yeah education unfortunately like a lot
of my citizens average it very educated
but I have a lot of like the sort of
lower-class industry so that's
employment so those ones are freaking
out so then how do you get water guys
who were like please okay so for example
inside just built those houses you can
see that there's no
going this house you could build a pipe
from the existing pipe structure Oh easy
and everything kind of works in these
raises like yeah basically so you don't
need to like send pot to every single
house to get me general area one unique
thing is districts so you can actually
paint districts areas suburbs or whatnot
and then have use that to sort of
observe how everyone's doing basically
said like this Business Park you can
tell like um I want to just find out how
their businesses are doing yeah how
they're happy how happy they are in that
kind of respect yeah and you can also
use districts to apply different policy
school so you can say you guys need to
conserve power you're not allowed to you
only moderate energy consumption yeah
you guys can save water you know no pets
so I've got a lot of note pet sort of
policies and these high density
residential area okay high density
buildings make so much garbage yeah I
don't want to just have to build like 10
like Lancope it's yeah you guys no pets
less garbage and in the same vein I'm
cycling or level three public transport
that's good so then people get the glass
right yeah it sprays good for them and
you might choose like tax by tax hikes
for specific sort of industries and sort
of residential new things City Planning
so I can get like perks for businesses
so they would come in come and make more
money and I'll get more money yeah
because of that high-rise bands which
other bands so on and so forth and I got
to say like one of the complaints about
SimCity 2013 aside from the off why is
the size of the map right this is 15
years so you start off with a plot of
land which is the size of the SimCity
stop well yeah I'd say maybe like around
that big uh-huh but put very early on
you can start buying more plots of land
so I would stand it out here and I click
on the global map oh yeah I games
have all of that land yeah as part of
that one city and like I feel like this
cities already getting like a little bit
big yeah and in my other city I just put
a high-density everywhere and they go
way too crazy but I've yet to see like
someone actually really effectively
build yeah that would be me there's just
so much detail in this game so much [ __ ]
to do
and there's anymore there's gonna be
like infinite amounts because the
modding is like yeah that community is
going oh it's going off it's like very
heavily like supported and encouraged by
the developer so you can see these
intersections that I have right here
actually download from the Steam
Workshop the time and patience managed
to put together a unique and you know
very effective highway intersection I
could just use that for my city yeah so
and it's super easy I've never seen such
an easy modest system integrate into a
game so I'm gonna go into it and will
and encourage you to make your own [ __ ]
and like upload to seem workshop yeah I
mean it's right there like like that
they clearly care a lot about you
getting your onesie and dirty with this
game I mean yeah and so it's it's stuff
from like maps we can make our own Maps
assets like the sort of intersections
and you can get custom shops and stuff
yeah like like mods like hard mode
there's a sort of default bet automatic
bulldozers is something that I put on oh
yes like when your house get bad again
oh yeah is it like tree brushes like FPS
display gremlin will camera yeah turn
that on and just so much other stuff
cool I don't need to do is like go into
the asset editor I'm gonna say I want to
make a cool thing for the internet and
you can do a cool thing and then people
play you're cool see ya space it's it's
great even for your own game and just
for your own personal use because saying
you want to build like a intersection
yourself yeah you don't want to have to
spend keep spending money and we'll
losing the stuff you messing it up right
yeah you just sort of like make it in
here
yeah just making it here like everyone
like pain with trees if I can pay the
trees yeah everything's right in there I
just want what you really want
I just want a triangle good people get
around and then you just take a
screenshot of it like that like so you
save it as that is so easy
my sweet intersect from there you just
upload Justine macho one of the
complaints the game that I have seen is
the lack is sort of like maps so all the
maps are kind of very plain like they're
very like bright and sunny yeah raining
and you know wet I guess isn't yeah and
there's there's some like deserts and
stuff yeah you know they've they also
again encourage people to make their own
maps awesome we can make our own cool
Sim City place that's great yeah I mean
you've been playing it like how are you
finding come with anything like a world
build ah I'm finding it like
semi-difficult yeah but it's nice to get
into and I think because they have those
particular things like everybody has
their are in car and they're earned
actual lives it feels more like a city
simulator than Sim City did yeah
Sim City had some nice elements but I
feel like this capitalizes on everything
that it did well and then it does more
stuff yeah and there is so much to worry
about like it's impossible to get into
everything yeah in here yeah there is
some other thing that you can a degree
of detail and like everything you do
affects everything else yeah that yeah
if this is a game that will suck up your
life and I yeah I spent like video so
how long did you spend making that
second town like how long does it take
to get something like that well I think
the second time I've maybe spent like
I'd say maybe just under 10 hours right
but it's not too bad but this was my
first city I'll just load it up and it's
it's a mess like I just I just wanted to
make New York I just wanted to make like
gigantic skylines I learned that yet
trash is a big problem
yeah like these guys that situation is
terrible my streets are a mess because
I'm intersections everywhere it's like a
grid which sounds great on principle
there yeah for the traffic blaring like
heavy industry stuff it's not like
fantastic like I've built pull this [ __ ]
on a mountain which was really hard
I built this sort of like satellite
kagura rail industry which is really
poor idea because they had to add their
own power plant for them god I'm so
insightful and I just wanted to like put
everything on the map Sarah yeah go like
Singapore style have a port town here
with like harbours cargo and like they
get their own wind generators and like I
just want to make clearly straights that
one yeah like this is this is this looks
huge again but like I can fill out once
i unlock these ones in the edge so I can
just keep going a guy yeah and one last
thing I went to share was something that
everyone's been talking about lately
which is the Los Santos map from gta5
and someone has made on the Steam
Workshop so let's load it up you just
download from there same workshop and
just it's in your savegames
yeah loaded and the Creator has a warm
that this Tennyson fili in there yeah
some things you can do that's that's a
real city simulator
reject so this is they completely male
awesome - so grand theft auto five
neighborhoods at all like with such
striking attention to detail oh my gosh
it's basically in LA a sort of mirror
that yeah it's
detail it's like the crap in the water
yeah I I haven't really wanted to like
try and fix the city's problems because
any bit this is all the scrolling
intersections I can't imagine how much
time they get days all right yeah so
you've got like Trebek the town
whichever is from oh yeah yeah the top
of Mount chiliad holy crap everything is
just like even though that I've been
used power lines for the cable car yeah
oh yeah even like the winding path is
like still it's kind of like true to
life or one to one that's cool yeah this
is insane and it's so huge as an fit on
my screen my zoom all the way out so
they've used all the blocks we use
pretty much and yeah you can make what
you take in city skyline how exciting
Zee Cine bilva I would say yeah from
colossal and paradox and like they've
just yeah they've said they're gonna
keep supporting it with mods yeah you're
gonna keep rolling up data like they've
had a bit of problems with piracy
mm-hmm and they've said well screw that
with let you pirate it but we're gonna
make the game the best experience
possible lasting like rolling up there
it's yeah it'll be really cool
yeah I've been obsessed with this game I
know a lot of people have been obsessed
at this game so yeah sweet you like it I
do I think it's full of possibility and
I'm really keen to try and mustard so
yeah that was City skylines
you